[موسيقى]
سيربو كوسوفو غاضبون نظمت اكبر احزاب
الاقليه العرقيه هذا الاعتصام جنوبي
البلاد جاءوا بالالاف للتنديد باصابه
اثنين منهم برصاص شرطي من الاغلبيه
الالباني
تمكن من العيش هنا يجب ان لا يتكرر ذلك
مجددا
هذه عائله الفتى المصاب تنفي كل ما اشيع
عن اغلاق الطريق قبل حادث اطلاق النار
عندما راني مع خالته انهار باكيا ولكن ما
الذي يمكننا فعله حمد لله انه مازال حيا
ونحن سعداء لذلك
ايام العام في عيد ميلاد المسيح
[موسيقى]
من الاحتجاجات الصربيه الشماليه البلاد
هدات بفضل التدخلات دوليه بما سمح باعاده
فتح الطرق والمعابر والدفع باتجاه الحوار
بين الطرفين حكومه كوسوفي واعتقلت الشرطي
المشتبه فيه هو تحقق معه بينما كشف الرئيس
ان قوات حفظ السلام الدوليه رفض الطلبه
وارسال جنود سرب الى كوسوفو لحمايه
المدنيين قال ان قرار مجلس الامن رقم
1244 يخوله ارسال 1000 جندي لكن القرار
صدر في التسعينيات القرن الماضي قبل ان
تعلن كسوف استقلاللها وبين سجل الحكوميتين
يحاول الناس هنا ان يحافظوا على بقي من
سلم اهلي
اطلاق النار الذي وقع هنا يخشى ان يتحول
الى مفترق طرق يغير مسار الهدوء الذي تحقق
بعد اسابيع من التوترات فحوادث تبدو عرضيه
كهذه شكلت في مرات كثيره سابقا شراره
لاضطرابات استمرت اشهر وسنوات محمد
المدهون الجزيره من جنوبي